[Music]
foreign
Pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin McGuire and the
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine welcome
to both of you
um yes not hard to guess tonight is it
let's have a look at the front pages
then
let's start with the financial times the
headline hunt defies the Gloom with an
upbeat budget the Metro calls today's
announcements and Easy Does It budget
the express is in an upbeat mood too
declaring will make this work for
Britain
the news that fuel duty is to stay
frozen spots this headline in the sun
tanks a lot
the guardian's verdict more damning they
describe it as a giveaway for the one
percent likewise the mirror the headline
there pots for the rich
the eye says that what we've seen is
actually a four pence in the pound
income tax Rise by stealth on the same
theme the time says we now have the
biggest tax burden since the war the
telegraph leads with the problems that
Credit Suisse which it says are stoking
fears of a new global banking crisis and
on a completely different note the star
has the tall story of a six foot four
jockey who will be taking part in the
racing at Cheltenham tomorrow well a
reminder by scanning the QR code you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch the program
so let's head then to Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine
um so let's do the Ft first of all shall
we although I think they might have
updated their paper with Credit Suisse
but we'll come to that later uh hunt
defies the Gloom with an upbeat budget
certainly better news on the prospect of
recession and indeed on inflation today
Sarah
yes so um what technically that we're
not going to go into recession this year
and they're predicting that the uh
inflation will be down will be at 2.9 by
the end of the year it's interesting the
evolution of the budget during the
course of the day because I think at the
beginning it was quite well received and
then of course throughout the day the
various sort of partisan papers have
sort of solidified their views and taken
much more polarized uh points you so the
Ft I think is still quite it's still
quite a good measure of of this budget
which is sort of I'd say a cure I'd say
good in Parts you know it's it's it's
it's not as bad as it could have been
it's certainly much better than
quasi-core Tang's budget
um and I think hunt delivered it well I
think he seemed quite confident
um and I'm surprised no one's made a
joke about all the e he's clearly been
taken with his three E's
um but there we go the headline writers
haven't been doing that today so we'll
see I think the the credit Swiss story
will start to come up now uh during the
course of the night yes um four e's if
you include the everywhere which was
left yes
um anyway the The Daily Express as well
will make this work for Britain the
spring budget especially you know all
sorts of pages pages and pages and all
of this uh before we get to the detail
and some of the criticism we see in the
papers your take Kevin
yeah I think I think all those E's I
think there's no ecstasy about this
budget anywhere I quite like that pun
for the express probably the most loyal
paper in an old Fleet Street uh
supporter of the UK conservative
government but I like it we'll make this
work for Britain when hunt was talking
about uh work and he replying that to
the entire budget I thought um and like
Sarah I thought his delivery was very
flat and uh somewhat dull monotone but
the
I think the reason the budget's Fallen
apart or doesn't look as shiny tonight
as it did at the time as a course it's a
very political speech by a chance Larry
it was well briefed in advance with uh
press releases and so on and he wants to
show as any Chancellor would label one
two in the best possible light but then
when you get under the under the Bonnet
of the figures and you look at them they
uh they aren't quite as rosy because
yeah yes there'll be no recession but
the economy will still shrink the
economy that's still the only G7 major
economy smaller than it was at the time
of covert and then you go through is
there enough money for child care
because there's a great policy in
principle but will it actually work how
long will it take to come in and then
you look at those stealth tax Rises
we'll see some of the other papers
income tax because the bands won't go up
29 billion he'll take there's going to
be a huge rower around pensions for the
wealthiest now one billion labors uh
planning to vote against them and House
of Commons trying to turn it into a 45p
tax
row that we saw with the quasi-court
Anglers trust Tory Kamikaze budget so I
I think that I think that's why it's
it's not as uh it's not as shiny as it
was because it was well briefed all the
nice bits but you know the worst bits
weren't and uh and some of them are
pretty pretty Grim for households and
I think uh Hud's been so smug and
obvious I think that will jar with many
families who are still suffering and
know they will continue to suffer for
some time yes just on the Metro and the
ease they certainly pick up on that easy
does it as their front page headline and
the ease were Enterprise education
employment and obviously everywhere as
as we mentioned but let's go to the
guardian then shall we the giveaway for
the one percent Labor's take on this uh
pension change and Hunt budget puts the
wealthiest in line for enormous tax
cards you know they said this was
specifically about senior doctors and
Consultants even senior head teachers
some suggested if they've worked for
long enough that they're butting into
their lifetime allowance because they've
got fixed pension contributions and it's
driving people from the market at a time
when the NHS needs those people in place
is that enough of a justification do you
think Sarah for this policy right now in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
um I I think I think given the trouble
that the NHS is experiencing we've got
all these strikes today with these
Junior doctors
um and some of the reporting around that
is quite interesting because they seem
to be
uh one of them is talking about how much
fun they were having making all their
patients go to a e and causing the Max
and disruption I think it's I think it's
a it's a bold move but I think it's
necessary they've got to keep these
consultants in work I mean I'm surprised
with the guardian being such a kind of
Beacon of feminism hasn't gone on the
child care policy which I think is
actually quite Progressive and actually
long overdue
um the idea that most women actually
basically pay just to be able to stay in
the in in the workplace so that they
don't drop out
um is is a is an outrage that's existed
in this country for many years and the
idea now that that's going to eventually
end uh you're going to be able to get
child care from the age of nine months
of your child which will enable women to
go back to work without being penalized
which is what's always happened
um but obviously uh that doesn't suit
The guardian's Narrative so they're
leading on the one percent well
yesterday though didn't they I mean kept
Kevin the idea was possibly that that
was going to be the rabbit and the
guardian got it is that is that what
happened
yeah well it looks like it's got the mix
of mitosis to take when people are doing
the numbers on on child care I think I
think Sarah's been a little bit harsh
there because the the child care was
well briefed in advance had been so much
coverage on TV Rodeo really other net
papers including the guardian and I I
think this is the they've gone for the
story now because the abolition of the
lifetime uh limit on pensions was not
briefed out who were figures around 1.5
million 1.8 million but there's no
abolition and while the ft and the
express which we've discussed I think
the the government will be quite happy
with those front pages it won't like
this one because it's in the cost of
living crisis giving a large amount of
money a billion pound to a small number
of people uh and let labor of crunch the
uh the figures from official sources
claiming it'll for each person who gets
back into the workforce it'll cost 75
000 pounds now there is an alternative
of course a scheme would have done been
done specifically for the NHS there was
a special scheme for judges for instance
in the in the public sector to stop them
all going off and be embarrassed and
getting more money
um footballers have also have their own
scheme that can get their pensions uh
access some access from earlier so there
are probably other other provisions and
labor is going to make a big Ballyhoo
with this as I said they're going to now
vote against it and try and turn it into
a new 45 Peak tax rate I'm not quite
sure it'll be that successful because
that was against the backdrop of a lot
of other tax changes in the budget that
sent a pound plummeting required a bit a
bailout Rescue of the Pension funds and
had to had to be reversed but since
there's no doubt just to clarify someone
has taken a risk here and it made that
fire off so they'll oppose it labor has
said and then what is the idea that
they'll reverse it is that is that what
what might happen and if so how does
anybody plan for their pensions given
we've got a general election next year
yeah well you're quite right that's a
question they will have to have to face
if they're going to oppose it now and
say it shouldn't happen What happens if
it does happen what are they going to
the next general election saying that
saying they're going to do will they
just freeze it would they penalize
anybody who had money over uh I think
those are questions that uh will have to
be asked and require answers well there
was one uh comment on social media I I
saw today it's not about doctors it's
about the income bracket that pays the
vast majority of income tax in this
country so this is clearly broader than
Consultants isn't it but just looking at
the you know the idea of getting people
back to work be it child care be it the
pension ports be it return ships
whatever it might be
um the obr suggesting that it that will
only actually encourage 110 000 people
into work when we have seven million
economically inactive people in this
country it's a lot of money Sarah as a
giveaway today to encourage this return
return ship for a hundred and ten
thousand people
well I mean we don't know if that's the
case do we I mean that's what the obr is
saying but they could be wrong I I I
can't you know I I I I don't understand
enough about economics to know whether
or not uh it's a total waste of money
but it seems to me that the general
direction of travel which is to
encourage people to go back to work and
particularly people who have a lot of
really important skills like doctors
Etc it seems to me a good political
principle I mean you know I just don't
see uh why why you would really object
to that well a political what's good I
think what's going to power the economy
and the reason why there's going to be
no recession not not what the government
is spending it is two two reasons one is
the is stupid unexpected fall in
International Energy prices after the
the Putin's invasion of Ukraine and
certainly higher immigration into
Britain
but that's the point isn't it you know
all of this money spent on returning you
know people with mental health issues in
this country or those on long-term
possibly with long covered and effort to
get them all back to work because Jeremy
Hunt Sarah won't press the lever to give
visas in specific sectors for foreign
workers to come to this country
well I mean that is that is a much
bigger bigger political question and and
I I think that um they probably should
think about doing that definitely I
don't really you know I don't really
understand what the big obstacle is
um it seems to me that you can do that
fairly successfully and with you know in
in a fairly orderly fashion and maybe
they'll maybe they will do that
yeah and I I philosophically agree with
Sarah that if if you can work you should
work we shouldn't give up on people we
should we should help them get into work
if there are barriers either medically
disabled or mentally problems or child
care or re-skilly whatever it is we
should we should do that but rather
rather a large number of people since
covert have decided that they prefer not
to work and if they're not on benefits
and they can support themselves I'm
afraid you're not going to get them back
in they just just think right I'll have
a bit of uh less cash but I'll have more
Leisure Time the mirror also going on
there's pots for the rich talking about
the pension pot and that lifetime
allowance and also saying nothing for
public sector workers who are striking
outside
um and you know we heard Jeremy Hunt
there say that The Strife is caused by
inflation uh but saw inflation falling
you know I've always wondered if
delaying any pay settlement as inflation
Falls helps the government out Sarah
yes I think you're right on that I think
that's what they're banking on as so to
speak which is that the inflation will
come right down and then and then
waiters will not seem so devalued
um you know it seems to me a perfectly
sensible strategy
the sun uh tanks a lot picking up on
what they say is they keep it down
Crusade
um about freezing fuel Duty uh some
people questioning whether this policy
um which actually costs more than the
five billion pounds offered to defense
in the next year is the is the right way
round but the whole point is we're in an
energy cost crisis aren't we Kevin
yes although the demand it's a very
marginal impact on inflation it's not
really falling because of what the
government was doing again it's a it
went up for for reasons International
reasons and it'll come down for them as
well but it was a Paul Johnson Institute
physical studies pointed out this will
cost six billion pounds so is that a
good expenditure of six billion pounds
where that would quite easily resolve
almost all the public service key worker
strikes that were we're seeing now but
there's some campaign on it hunt has
gone for it uh although it's get its
worth pointing out the social Market
Foundation has sent the right think tank
on Monday had a report that's showing
actual fuel Duty freezers and cuts the
vast majority of that goes to wealthier
households because they'll have bigger
cars bigger engines sometimes two cars
so it's not really white white van man
who benefits or families that are
struggling it is better off people okay
that's interesting and Jeremy hunts
commented on that asked whether he was
right to increase the pension port and
said you know it's right to keep those
experienced workers in the market as
they are older they will be paid more
but five times more money has gone to
younger parents in this budget than to
that pension pot Sarah I interrupted you
no no I just wanted to say the other
thing the one thing I do think that is
slightly worrying is that they haven't
extended this fuel uh help to businesses
to small businesses and of course they
you know so I think swimming pools get
to get some help with the with heating
the pools but generally you know small
businesses are not getting any help with
energy costs which are really crippling
them and I do think that is a bit of a
missed uh trick for him there because I
think traditionally you know small
businesses have always been uh important
to the conservative party base um you
know that that would have been something
I would have looked at yes and these
swimming pool announcement got a bit of
a chuckle in the comments did it not
after news of Rishi sunak anyway in his
in his constituency anyway lots more
still to come a big day of news
elsewhere to on any other day a collapse
of shares for one of Europe's biggest
banks would have been a much bigger
story we will be talking about the fears
about Credit Suisse when we come back
foreign
[Music]
with me once again Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine um Kevin let's go to the
Daily Telegraph
um another version of the Ft also
leading on this the concerns about Swiss
bank with the telegraph suggesting there
are emergency meetings tonight with the
bank of England and its International
counterparts on this
no absolutely this is this is hugely
important it's the 17th largest bank in
uh in Europe has a royal real role in
setting uh setting rate made 6.6 billion
losses Saudi National Bank so they
couldn't give it any more cash because
it's regular regulated to 10 and you
know the ftse 100 the share a Stock
Exchange in the UK is like 75 billion
pounds not knocked off uh this because
it reverberates around the world and
there are just fears of another banking
collapse we saw the Silicon Valley Bank
go uh go under rescued in Britain by
HSBC which Jeremy Hunter Chancellor says
won't cost tax appears anything but no
this is this is we're this is worrying
and it can be a contagion that can
spread uh everybody will be trying to
calm the markets and investors
speculators but of course everyone will
also be looking over their shoulders we
all think back to what happened in 2007
2008 now this is probably not comparable
to that but nevertheless it revives very
very bad memories yes sorry to interrupt
you the Swiss National Bank has come out
tonight and said it would provide credit
suites with liquidity if necessary
Credit Suisse said it welcomed that
statement of support uh the Swiss
banking regulator also suggesting
tonight that Credit Suisse meets the
capital and liquidity requirements for
big Banks and this is a Whopper isn't it
second biggest bank in Switzerland which
is known for its banking sector Sarah
yes I mean I think it's it is a Whopper
you're completely right because Credit
Suisse is is considered by many to be
the absolute gold standard of banks you
know it's it's and also it's it's
Switzerland it's it's meant to be boring
and safe and efficient with money and so
the idea that credit Swiss is in trouble
is really frightening because then you
think well if that's you know if that's
the top of the tree then where's
everybody else so and and I think people
think quite rightly you know we've only
just finished off finished but we're
just from paying off the last lot of
Bankers who made a gigantic mess of the
World by investing in lots of terrible
poor Investments that didn't work and
what are we going to have to do it all
over again I mean no wonder people are
hiding underneath their duvets and it
does seem it and 2008 for me doesn't
feel like that long ago I mean I
remember living through it and it was
horrendous and very frightening and and
and we've already just gone got out of
covert I mean it's I just don't know
that we can take an another big mistake
yes the Second National version of the
financial times has the falls in the
banking sector on stock markets uh today
some really big drops credit Suites
alone uh down 24 points and as many
people point out how many times does
socialism have to bail out capitalism
that's sort of you know what we've seen
isn't it
um Kevin just a very quick word on that
I haven't done the other stories
apologies carry on yeah private profits
public losses it's an old story so in
the energy sector here it's a
that's why I favor a lot much more
widespread public ownership of uh part
of the finance Industry gas electricity
water rail mail could go on I'm sure I
think you get away with that one I
didn't get to the six foot something
Kevin and Sarah thank you both very much
indeed uh we will see you for more at 11
right